I don't like massage you never had a
massage I don't like him I saw here yeah
yes get him all the time man not go Vai
go Far East on my back yeah yeah yeah
you you you know what dude that makes so
much sense that you get so many massages
I love you seem like a guy that would be
like once I get some money man
you get rubbed all over time I have some
seek on my Obama bring out till the
butter man please have a dip in a vat
all over my back man I wanna member
Sargent different parts of me bad that's
when you would just my feet the whole
five minutes and then just spend five
minutes on the back of my neck I'm good
wannabes Jeff Foxworthy what's his name
Foxworthy that's you yeah yeah you go
like this the hip factor bro from the
back quiznos oh look that way get I'm
not joking dude you guys get a little
thicker they're getting a little thicker
dude I do squat you've got some ham easy
you turn it in to clear a table kind of
a lot of people say thank you do it I
would [ __ ] do that in a heartbeat
Vegas just look at all [ __ ] hey as
well as what Where's Waldo and man
Where's Waldo an audio tape just making
a [ __ ] is my invention Where's Waldo
an audio David I'm bill I'm Frank I'm
Waldo found him who's ever seen the show
but it sounded good funny Jake when he
did that I laughed my [ __ ] Sean said
was [ __ ]
oops I'm allowed to interrupt is my show
all right
yeah it's called Floyd's do you must
have to go sleep I love you guys cuz I
love you guys man we know what I'll do I
love you guys I don't think that's it I
love to you and you know it's [ __ ]
like Rock of Love I want people to let
me know yeah you want clarity yeah we
all I don't want like this [ __ ] we all
do
yeah I don't get it though like some guy
I was I let him know about my [ __ ] oh
yeah launches over my go sit by the
window in zero we're gonna find the kid
oops you interrupted me yeah now the
danger in that is you don't get a jewel
right well the danger in you
interrupting me is if you don't let
daddy drop a jewel right now we all like
jewels just bad yeah yeah people are
dying
exactly I'm gonna [ __ ] give you some
hot hot heat if I'm gonna give you a
[ __ ] lasagna of a conversation right
[Applause]
because your jewels
I wanna make sure your now go ahead give
us the hollows on us well I know I'm
sober apologize no I'm not apologizing
for Schumer as I forget it now let me
[ __ ] remember what it is and everyone
be silent until I [ __ ] remember what
it is you've told the quiet no I can't
remember no [ __ ] dude those hot lasagnas
gone dude no such lasagnas so good
though yeah I love it hot though innit I
got a couple things that number you suck
the boys I hold on number one you take
it sunglasses off and take your put your
collar [ __ ] down first of all just
let yourself he said he said one thing
that's two things okay and I will tell
you this do what I you know I you know
why I can't take my sunglasses off you
know why want to say it together or what
not stand
future exactly right he's not taking him
now my collar I try to put it down but
it doesn't go down why I I think it's a
cool thing
nothing just like a [ __ ] might--might
I put it down and it goes like this and
I put it down and then it goes like this
you're too cool yeah I don't think that
is fair it's not fair
besides the other guys on the street and
they got their colors down and I go
what's going on and they go like this
well Chris drink of water I'm six
nothing now they're couple of things too
before we get to the sweater because I
want royalties we're not gonna get to
that for a second cuz this is my thing
now hold on chin I want you to go to my
Instagram I wanna I wanna I want to show
what kind of a supportive friend Chris
is and I want to get into this for a
second
I want to get into this go to my
Instagram I'm here yeah no I hear you
well now I'm gonna be in Phoenix this
Saturday celebrity theater get your
tickets guys go go to my good just go to
the just go to the [ __ ] thing chin no
no to Phoenix to the Phoenix where I'd
yeah okay you go I can't move
now sweet what is the first comment
what's the first comment on there hey
everyone don't go to this apologize
right now and tell my fans I do not only
see me in Phoenix this Saturday but also
at the Wilbur theater New Year's [ __ ]
Eve do I will say this I want to say
this cuz I'm gonna take mine off okay
that's cool man we're inside it's also
it takes me a little bit longer to take
mine off but it's fine dude I am [ __ ]
still so young okay you're almost four
never [ __ ] I mean you're almost but
it's a forward it's a feeling you
understand and I just have not had a
feeling since I was young and you know
I'm the [ __ ] youngest guy you know
okay I'm doing so here's the other thing
dude I do what I want right and when I
have to do something I don't want I go
like this
not having it so I don't want people to
go to your show that is if you're gonna
make me say why don't you that's so
blatantly spiteful I know I know I'm
just gonna live in it hey did you have
to do it long as it helps bro yeah what
what are the emojis ahead of that
educate those are the alarms going off
like brah hey everyone don't go to this
like if you were in a building you'd be
like what's happening and they'd be like
don't go to the run : show and they'd be
like oh well we weren't gonna go anyway
but we'll make sure
now we're really not I'm very nice to
you I'm not physical with you and you're
very you couldn't it's a good thing the
internet came along when you guys were
what are you saying yeah I'd say what
else would you guys a little stroke II
what's going on what do you think I'm
not stroking out I love you let's make
it sure I care about no no if you're
[ __ ] the top of your hair like the
[ __ ] back of a duck's ass and I tell
you what everyone knows it and people go
with sometimes I'm at the comics or
Netflix when you walk by that's what I
hear right do sometimes you'll go by and
they're like for other dog that's what
they do
and there's always that one gay duck
that's kind of just looking bad
Brendan's da cool shoes you can't get
yet on I got this new tattoo at 40 and
then you go plane taking off that's a
plane but it's a plane going around the
world man
Road Dogg lies you know why no why did
you get a Boeing 707 a bro because it's
a small plane Wayne it you go to Denver
it's not here
[ __ ] bifocals outlook you can hurt
your bag deal deal what do you think of
Brian in Chris's Christmas sweater dude
it looks good man I think this was my
invention I think one day I said dance
and then you took it
oh those are fightin words dude it was
fighting some resists I want some
risotto yeah you deserve it you can have
some of the money wouldn't make it bad
[Laughter]
but I do do you admit one thing can we
admit one you won't do it but yes every
one thing it's not a bad look I want it
let's think back a little bit cuz you
have a little bit of amnesia right so
let's think back at the end of the day
wait is this a fair statement this is a
fair thing this guy that I that I told
you from my red boot is that fair that
would not be fair okay that would not be
fair but I made you when you were young
and lost no that was no I would not say
that good cuz I would always look at you
and I when I went out when I was coming
up and I would be like Brian and you
don't look down at me like that
but yes where you are so yeah not a lot
but you just feel like a little more
like here and you're just getting a
little bit smaller process is good it's
this minds doing crunch me back I was
training oh I had a no-no hold on one
second man you were training what man
you were training all right my friend is
a recon marine of course he is and he
he's recon take you to the next level
we're gonna do some exes close it I'm
actually I have a nephew that's recon
duties in a special you like a special
Academy or something yeah they're no
joke
no joke take it from me if there's no no
it was doing it cuz also one of the next
level where's the first level for ya do
it with the Recon man there's only the
next level what is I'm moving my mech
like this right as I did like you're
cheating Batman I had a balance on a
[ __ ] on a kettlebell and I was like
this is a bad idea
and I had to go and open up keep this is
a bad idea and I went I went tweaked and
it went tweaked and I right ah that's
gonna be a problem for the next five
days you need your on roids we've been
over they can't wait T on roids do you
know yeah yeah fro if you got how funny
would it be if wouldn't be hilarious
more e-cig I'd love to see you know what
for I'm good for viewers - not that you
need it you have a successful podcast
Thank You Brendan to a mannequin -
that's a really good point that's going
to shave and I'm wearing makeup from my
[ __ ] TV shows because it really
belongs to me listen man you're welcome
for this it fits you nice and tight yeah
wait Oh in in a quake recall your Cueto
and you're the guy and when he goes I
want to you're below this guy that's you
he's all yeah the wet baby the wet baby
yeah you're the wet baby should bring up
wet baby from Tori wait on Cueto that's
his name oh that's Brian Carolyn that
should be the new poster for fighter in
the kid is here when the guy takes off
his thing
oh yes you you a - for the third row
third row to the right hot chilly right
there bro that's Brian Brendan Krause
yeah what is a baby yeah very true yeah
he like whispers OH
mmm that's like your body Chris that's
just dude Chris has a subcutaneous level
of fat I don't bro subcutaneous you just
said I was shredded I showed you the
Shred zone weekend celebrity theater
Chicago
[ __ ] you've shut up you're noisy make
sure you fly to Chicago Chicago come to
come to Boston for New Year's Eve
because I'll be at the Wilbur so you can
choose Christopher you can choose the
guy who came you know Chris came for my
rib so come see the real thing you're
gonna be in Chicago I don't even give a
[ __ ]
Chicago I got three shows at the Chicago
theater how many tickets you do the math
you're doing one into Wilbur yeah so far
we might add another one you never know
cuz tickets are going fast
yeah is that way you're promoting other
podcasts I don't like that attitude
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]